try and find a concrete line where you  you can sort of um  you can sort of hold at least to be um  be relatively safe and now yeah bishop  f3  does seem to surprise hikaru a little  bit  um even though  even though it's uh it's it's an it's an  obvious move it's  uh removing a knight that could have  been very very  very strong if it had been allowed to  jump undoubling  white's pawns but maybe it wasn't  maybe it wasn't the first choice of the  computer  maybe he car also is  a little bit puzzled that he's given  he's given a choice between taking the  with the queen  and the pawn uh let's say if mishra had  taken the queen  first and then taken the knight he  wouldn't have had  he wouldn't have had that choice so  maybe that's what he's thinking about